alright guys you know who I am and I'm
not gonna waste any time all right I'm
not gonna do some silly ass intro for
this [ __ ] it's time to get down to
business and I know what you guys are
thinking you're thinking Jerry the
intros are why watch this show watching
you waste time trying to figure out how
to tell us what movie you're talking
about in a clever way is the reason I
tune into the show I'm not tonight folks
I'm not gonna do an intro not tonight
it's time to get right down to business
and talk about some cinemas okay because
there's a movie coming out I don't know
if you all know but it's the age of
Adaline that's right
Blake Leslie has been alive for a
hundred years and [ __ ] just getting
crazy all right now I know what you're
thinking Jerry that's not the movie we
want to see this weekend and you know
what you're right you're absolutely
right because I'm just [ __ ] with you
man you know what movie you're here to
talk about that's right the one the only
well technically one in a sequence of
movies kind of this is like the tenth
one but you know what I'm trying to say
adventures the age of Ultron hmm okay so
I am in the car it's dark and I know
what you're thinking to yourself you're
thinking Jerry it's really dark can't
see your face very well well too bad
because I wanted this I don't know why
I'm yelling at you guys hi it's nice to
see you again
um too bad you're gonna have to deal
with it because this is first
impressions time all right I caught this
film at 8 p.m. on Thursday and I'm gonna
talk about it at 11:15 13 on Thursday hi
Dada here we go
Avengers the age of Ultron the next in
the sequence the end of phase 2 [ __ ]
more [ __ ]
alright so ha ha
mistre okay so the Avengers age of
Ultron kicks right back into action
almost as if our heroes had never been
apart they're together they're working
to recover Loki's scepter so that they
can send it back to Asgard and have
everything be peachy and stuff like that
and of course along the way [ __ ] goes
down man [ __ ] goes wrong because they
discover some [ __ ] inside of that
scepter and you know I don't want to get
too deep into the plot but you know they
start playing with it and they unleash
Ultron that's like the Vegas version of
this plot because I really don't want to
spoil any surprises because to be
truthful to you guys I didn't know much
about the plot of this movie all right
me and Ryan have reacted to a lot of
clips a lot of trailer but you know I
haven't been paying that much attention
to the trailers because I was excited to
see this movie as fresh as possible you
know because there are a lot of big loud
you know spectacle movies that come out
and it's hard to have them all be
special and I like the Avengers man I
like Marvel I wanted this to be special
so basically as they're taking apart and
sort of looking into what is at the core
of this scepter Tony gets this idea that
perhaps they can create something bigger
better than the Avengers something to
truly protect the world and make the
Avengers unnecessary bring about world
peace and along the way something goes
wrong man some goes down and here we
have Ultron the new super villain of the
Avengers universe and let's start there
because you know what Marvel movies if
there's one complaint some folks have
had about Marvel's films lately it's
that they've had some trouble with
villains you know and with any superhero
franchise the villain is what's always
gonna change you know that's
be a lot of the meets and a lot of the
interesting stuff and what presents a
lot of the challenges once we've had the
obligatory origins story gotten out of
the way and housed the villain in this
movie his name's in the [ __ ] title
man house Ultron Ultron is pretty
awesome from where I'm sitting right now
it's dark Ultron
voiced by James Spader from very many
movies and television shows some
blacklist right now James Spader great
actor he brings a lot of personality
with his voice to Ultron and Ultron
thank goodness is really a formidable
scary villain I mean I'm sitting there
through this movie being like I don't
know how they're gonna do this like he's
the most power ever so you know very
formidable villain very you know a lot
of really cool dialogue and stuff given
to him you know you can see that he came
from Tony Stark
so Ultron himself I really dug and how's
the rest of the Cavs let's get into that
I mean your favorite Avengers are back
Chris Evans Captain America Robert
Downey jr. is Iron Man Jeremy Renner as
Hawkeye scout Johansson's Black Widow
Mark Ruffalo as Bruce Banner the Hulk
and these guys are great I mean it's
great watching them together again and I
gotta tell you there's a scene in this
movie where they're at a party where
they're just kicking back after you know
an early victory and I gotta tell you I
would watch that scene as a whole movie
it was it's that fun so The Avengers
themselves are back in in full form and
there's been some criticism about this
movie being unintelligible and I guess
for onna on one hand I can get that
because this movie does move at a pretty
steady clip there's a lot of stuff going
on when it comes to a lot of the
intimate details of you know the master
plan of Ultron and stuff like that and
just things you doing those are easy
details to lose in you know the heat of
action and stuff like this you can tell
it's going on some of the discussion and
some of the explanations are a little
hard to like grab while things are
moving around you know cuz these movies
have to move and stuff like that but all
in all I enjoyed the story of this movie
I enjoyed how they you know brought the
Avengers back together and you know this
time it's a crisis that was created from
within you know it's not an outside
force I mean it is but it's an outside
force that was created by intimate parts
of the Avengers and I think that's a
cool way to go about this and you know
part of the thing that seems to make
both of these movies work is putting the
Avengers at odds and I think this movie
finds a cool way of doing that without
having to be exactly the same way of
doing that as the first movie because
there is a certain element of like he
wants us to tear each other apart but it
makes sense or at least it did to me at
the time you know Ryan and I are gonna
talk about this tomorrow but and how is
everything I mean there's plenty of
action and I was happy to see cuz a lot
of you know you read the capsule reviews
on Rotten Tomatoes you can't always tell
but there's a good amount of character
stuff in between in this movie also I
mean one of the greatest virtues this
movie has going for it is just the sheer
amount of humor you know it's like as
serious as things are and as much as a
stake the avengers themselves still have
a lot of chemistry and there are so many
witty lines and and little
back-and-forth dynamics that make this
movie a lot of fun give it a personality
so you know while the serious stuff is
serious it's not afraid to crack a smile
and keep us having fun and I think
that's the thing that Marvel has cracked
pretty well is how to make it seem like
there are things at stake but there's
still a sense of fun it's like you know
comic books can get heavy or gritty or
serious but there's still fun and
there's still humor in there and these
you know these characters are all sort
of
a fish out of water or they all have a
unique perspective in some way and I
like that this movie also dials up the
emphasis in certain ways on Black Widow
and Hawkeye even to the point that it
seems like Hawkeye is actually there
acknowledging how underappreciated he
feels as a character or as a part of the
team and I enjoyed that quite a bit the
new characters as well you know you have
a Scarlet Witch and you have Quicksilver
Quicksilver Quicksilver and they're a
cool addition to this plot and they have
different powers which is nice and I
mean I really liked both them in this I
mean you know they're this brother and
sister kind of in a shitty situation and
they've been experimented on and stuff
like that but you know their powers are
cool and thank goodness this is a
technical thing thank goodness because
x-men Days of Future past was able to
pull this off and so was the Avengers
age of Ultron and I'm just happy about
that it's hard to make someone running
really really fast look cool and they
made it look cool so good on you for
that um so yeah I really enjoyed Aaron
Johnson and Elizabeth Olsen I mean they
don't have giant things to do in this
movie but it's it's a big ensemble you
know that's part of the point and you
know I think because there are more
characters you know certain things do
get a little bit lost you you do
sometimes wonder where certain
characters went or whatever it's not
quite as tight maybe a balancing act to
just on first impression as the first
movie was but it does balance the
Avengers it gives each member you know a
reason for being there and it's a lot of
fun there's a lot of cool action there
are a lot of like neat little side
characters and they include some of the
characters from the other standalone
movies as well you know certain people
pop up that I wasn't expecting so I
don't want to ruin those surprises
you'll hear all about it in the spoiler
review tomorrow but keep your eyes out
because there are some fun little
appearances by people and then you also
you know you have Sam Jax's Nick Fury
here and they're not as much as I was
expecting which is actually got a cool
you know The Avengers are now their own
standalone
thing so this movie you know on first
impression I had a blast man I did lose
myself and I tried as best as possible
not to go into this with heavy
expectations because that's the big
thing this movie is facing the first one
just had to stick the landing and do it
right this one has to live up to how
well the first one does it and I'm sure
we'll get into more comparisons tomorrow
but you know that is a hefty job for
joss whedon and and all the people who
worked on this to pull off and pulled
together you know there's so many wheels
turning in the Marvel Universe right now
there are so many plans and phases and
and different things that I'm sure none
of us even know about
I gotta imagine making an Avengers movie
is a very difficult juggling act and I
think they did a fine job I had so much
fun with this and you know in the first
15 minutes 10 minutes or so you know I
was wondering if I would because you
know it kind of gets off to a bumpy
start for me you know I was having a
little trouble getting invested same
kind of happen to me with the first film
but you know once it gets to that party
scene man I was having a blast I was
having a lot of fun I was laughing a lot
it was clapping you know it was fun to
see with a bunch of people you know I
had a really good time and you know
there's some great additions to this
Paul Bettany man I really like I love
Paul Bettany in this with his increased
presence so I'm babbling this is first
impressions but you gotta know man you
know the effects are great you know
they're always you think they have
Disney money Marvel money ILM
Industrial Light and Magic money you
know they've got all of the toys and
they use them broody ones
so um yeah you know I had a blast I felt
like a kid you know at a certain point
during this movie so I really enjoyed it
I like this movie goes to different
places you know at one point there in
like Africa and then there in Eastern
Europe you know it's nice to see a big
superhero movie that doesn't destroy New
York for once right let's there are
other places in the world and that's
another part of what's cool about this
is that it feels like boo world is at
stake not just America is at stake so
that's a nice thing I like some of the
subplots you know I like the different
dynamics between the different
characters because part of the fun of
any Avengers movie is pairing off
characters this is what Bruce and Tony
talked about this is what happened when
Bruce and Natasha in the same room
together and you know I really like
those dynamics and as far his romantic
story goes again I won't get into it
this is probably my favorite of all the
attempts because the romance in all of
the Avengers related Marvel movies is
problematic to me but I like this inner
Asian and I also like but this movie
does bring in some pretty neat creative
stuff especially with Scarlet Witch
there are these really cool sort of
unsettling little nightmare sequences
that happen partway through the movie
and I wasn't expecting those and I
really liked the inclusion of those
things you know the movie gets to have a
sort of different style and there are
little flourishes here and there little
stylistic flourishes whether they come
from the score or the visual style or
you know any number of things even just
attention to detail I gotta give it up
to Joss Whedon for attention to detail
and putting personality places you know
so in the continued adventures of The
Avengers I had a really good time I left
feeling really happy I'm glad I saw it
I'd like to see it again you know is it
the greatest Marvel movie
I don't know right now and I don't care
right now because sometimes things
should just be allowed to be their own
thing for a few minutes
you know let's enjoy this one for the
moment and like I said Ryan and I are
gonna get together and talk about it a
whole spoiler review all that stuff but
from where I'm sitting right now the
cast is good the writing's pretty good
some of the story logistics get lost in
the shuffle of just like oh we gotta go
from place to place but like the
character stuff is cool the humor you
know the banter and stuff like that is
on point there's some cool visual
flourishes some neat details a very
formidable villain some interesting new
characters man I really enjoyed this
movie there's a lot more arguably that
they had to accomplish and I think they
accomplished it admirably I had a really
good time I think you will do I mean I'm
not a comic book expert but I've seen
all the movies but you know I had a
great time and I hope you do too so
that's where I'm at right now definitely
go check this out
so yeah moving forward I mean I know
Marvel's got their Slade out till like
2050 but uh what would you like to see
them include is there may be a character
you'd like to see them work in aside
from the obvious ones of course you know
or is there something you'd like to see
them do a book you'd like to see them
tackle or you know an actor you'd like
to see them add to the shuffle um so
yeah let's talk about that anyway
Avengers the age of Ultron is the movie
I am Jerry til next time
butch shears